this morning we are hearing for the very
first time from the family of a woman
charged in connection with the presumed
murder of a missing connecticut mother
we all remember this story jennifer
doulos disappeared
in may 2019 and her estranged husband
that's fotus duelist
was later charged with her murder but he
took his own life just weeks after he
was arrested
his former girlfriend michelle tracronus
is her name is facing charges
but insists that she has no idea what
happened to jennifer doulos
aaron moriarty spoke to trucronus family
for this week's 48 hours
these are the pictures that turned the
jennifer dulo's missing persons case
into a murder investigation the victim's
estranged husband photos
dulos with his girlfriend michelle
traconis
caught on surveillance cameras as he
dumps evidence in hartford connecticut
containing jennifer's dna it's not every
day someone throws up bloody evidence
bloody clothes cut up who does that
someone trying to get away with murders
says connecticut state police sergeant
kenneth ventresska we shifted gears
and we turned this into the homicide
investigation foda stullos was later
charged with the murder of his missing
wife
and michelle traconus with conspiracy to
commit murder
but three weeks later fotus dullos took
his own life
where does that leave michelle draconis
well
i think the right expression here is
she's
left holding the bag michelle trekonis's
attorney john schonhorn
says he's seen no evidence that she knew
jennifer was missing
when she and fotus made that trip to
hartford you're saying
she had no idea what
was in those bags that voters was
getting rid of she not only did not know
what was in those bags
she had no idea what he was actually
doing in recently released portions of
police interviews
michelle denies any involvement we think
you have
information
[Music]
whatever you want but i didn't do it but
detectives believe
she knows more than she's saying in one
interview michelle claimed photos was
with her the morning jennifer
disappeared
later she admitted she hadn't seen him
that morning so if you know
stuff that you're not telling us that's
the man
michelle's father carlos and sisters
claudia and daniela
are speaking out for the first time it's
been devastating
because we know my sister is innocent
sometimes women
do ridiculous things for love that's not
me
other woman but not myself will never
harm anyone
but would she possibly cover up for a
man she would never put herself
in her ways not even herself or her
daughter no
but police believe michelle may hold the
key to the mystery of the missing mom
i'm confident we are going to find our
body and we're not going to stop
every day i ask myself where's jennifer
boy erin this was such a bizarre story
because you have the mother is dead the
accused killer
her estranged husband is also now dead
and now they're accusing
now the girlfriend is on trial how
unusual is that
let's just start with that palm gail
this is
very unusual because remember jennifer
doulos has not been found
so what you have is you have michelle
traconus facing charges in the death of
a woman
she never met whose body has not been
found
um as her attorney says she was
left holding the bag you know there were
several
children involved in this case four or
five i kept thinking at the time i
really felt for the kids
and now they don't have either parent
does it
is it believable that the other woman
doesn't know
anything you're looking at your
boyfriend allegedly throwing away bags
of something it's just
sort of defies logic that you don't have
any idea what is happening here
i think that's going to be a problem for
her at trial but i should point out that
the night that those bags are being
thrown out
is the night that jennifer doulos is
reported missing and it's possible
michelle draconis
did not know she thought he's a
contractor he doesn't want to pay to
dump trash and he'd dump trash
so it's possible it's going to go down
to this this trial
very interesting case i'll be watching
saturday night thank you erin
you can watch aaron's report what does
the other woman know the disappearance
of jennifer doulos on 48 hours
that's tomorrow night at 10 9 central
right here on cbs